okay so mmm another question
voted out 77 votes Australia is holding
a plebiscite on whether to legalize gay
marriage I'm against the yes campaign
but only because it's backed by cultural
Marxists I'm curious to hear your views
on gay marriage well I would be against
tattoo of who was backed by cultural
Marxists because it isn't clear to me
that it will satisfy the ever-increasing
what would you call demand for an
assault on traditional modes of being
now with regards to gay marriage
specifically that's a really tough one
for me because you know I can imagine
I can't do anything really other than
spoke platitudes about it I suppose
unfortunately you know if if the marital
vows are taken seriously then it seems
to me that it's a means whereby gay
people could be integrated more
thoroughly into standard society and
that's probably a good thing and maybe
that would decrease promiscuity which is
a public health problem although
obviously that's not limited to gay
people
although gay men tend to be more
promiscuous than average probably
because there's no women to bind them
with regards to their sexual activity
the problem is is that it does seem to
me to be part of a wedge and it isn't
obvious to me that that legalizing gay
marriage has done anything to decrease
the demands that the radical left
neo-marxist types are placing on
traditional society so those are my
views I know they're confused you know
because I'm in favor of extending the
bounds of traditional relationships to
people who wouldn't be involved in a
traditional long term relationship but
I'm concerned about the undermining of
traditional modes of being including
marriage which you know has technically
and and historically being a union
between a man and a woman fundamentally
for the purpose of raising children in a
stable and and an optimal and stable
environment so a marriage has already
taken a fair bit of damage over the last
few decades you know poor people are
increasingly less likely to be married
and that's really not good for them as
far as I'm concerned